does it mean Michelin star Michelin  tires it comes from the tire company  it's real sorry it does it does Michelin  started a guide where they're like okay  we sell tires we'll make a system where  we'll give a bunch of recommendations of  great places to eat for you to stop at a  long year trip using Michelin tires no  one star is just for great food two  stars is great food and great service  three stars is like the Symphony of a  restaurant being utterly perfect someone  drops a napkin it gets picked up within  a certain amount of time so it ended up  becoming this really sort of difficult  to acquire award and human beings love  that